yep we have a uh a producer in the
courtroom who is texting me right now
that smallett is guilty on the first
five charges
uh we'll wait and see what happens on
that sixth charge he's charged with six
low-level felony counts of lying to
police there are varying charges in
there there is lying about a hate crime
because he's a black gay man there's
lying about battery because he was
injured and then there's lying about
aggravated battery because he said that
his attackers were wearing masks in
closing arguments yesterday the defense
pointed to six items that they felt uh
destroyed a smaller story they say that
he withheld critical evidence like his
cell phone data and his medical records
they say he misled police about his
attacker's id they say he faked evidence
by tampering with that rope without
noose around his neck they say he lied
about who attacked him uh they also said
that medical evidence corroborated the
osindora brothers story they say that
jesse smallett told them to hold their
punches when they hit him and a
northwestern doctor testified under oath
that jesse smallett had no known
injuries and the sixth point was that
jesse smallett never signed the criminal
complaint against the brothers police
testified the lead detective testified
that it's very rare or unheard of for a
hate crime victim not to sign a criminal
complaint against who they feel attacked
them bret
okay again the small advertised count
one guilty count two guilty count three
guilty count four guilty count five
guilty and we're seeing count six not
guilty
and that is just coming down from the
courtroom
in chicago